ننقل
اليك وليد تطورا كنا قد نقلناه قبل قليل
هو فعليا متعلق بتصريح
لاحد الاعضاء في مجلس الحرب الاسرائيلي
وهو فعليا وزير في مجلس الحرب جدعون ساعر
الذي صرح وقال بان اسرائيل بعيده جدا عن
انهاء حركه حماس هل من تفاصيل اكثر عن
خلفيات هذا التصريح بالاضافه بالتاكيد الى
الكثير من الت ورات
المتسارعه جدع سعر ليس وزيرا في مجلس
الحرب هو وزير في المجلس الوزاري الامني
المصغر المعروف بالكابينه وهو من حزب
معسكر الدوله الذي يراسه بني جانس في
تصريح نقلته اذاعه الجيش قال بان اسرائيل
ما زالت بعيده عن تقويض حركه حماس وان من
يفكر انه سيكون بامكانها اقامه او ان تقوم
سلطه اخرى اخر بديله لحماس في قطاع غزه
فهو واهم ما لم يتم تقويضها بالكامل وان
اسرائيل يجب ان تكون ملتزمه بتحقيق هذا
الهدف لان هناك رعب هائل حسب تعبيره مما
وصفه بارهاب حماس لدى المواطنين
الفلسطينيين المهم في تصريحه هو ان
اسرائيل ما تزال بعيده عن تقويض حركه حماس
هو ياتي امتدادا لتصريحات وتقديرات
اسرائيليه كثيره بان هذه الحرب حتى الساعه
والتي دخلت يومها ال12 لم تحقق تقدما
باتجاه تحقيق الاهداف التي حددتها الحكومه
الاسرائيليه منذ بدايتها وهي القضاء على
حركه حماس اعاده الاسرائيليين الاسرى
والمحتجزين في قطاع غزه وتوفير الامن
لسكان بلدات غلاف غزه هذه الامور لم تتحقق
لذلك تاتي مثل هذه التصريحات كما ان وزير
الدفاع اف جلنت في تصريحه الليله الماضيه
هو الاخر كان قد اشار الى ان الجيش
الاسرائيلي وان انهى
المرحله الثانيه من الحرب على في شمال
قطاع غزه فهو يواصل هذه المرحله وهي ما
سماها بالمناور البريه اي الاجتياح البري
في جنوبي القطاع وهو قريب من انهائها
لكنهم لم يعود يتحدثوا عما كان يردد في
البدايه باده حماس وما شابه لذلك تصريحات
مثل تصريحات الوزير ساعر او ما كان قد
اعلنه الوزير جلنت تشير الى ان الجيش الى
ان القيادتين العسكريه والسياسيه
الاسرائيليه مازالت تتخبط سياسيا وعسكريا
ويشار في هذا السياق الى ان جلنت كان قد
انحى
باللائحه الاسرائيليه حتى الان لم تحدد
رؤيه سياسيه او استراتيجيه سياسيه لهذه
الحرب واعتبر ذلك بانه انتقاد موجه الى
رئيس الوزراء نتنياهو الذي احبط سلسله من
الاجتماعات لمجلس الوزاري الامني المصغر
الكابينت كان من المقرر ان تبحث هذا
الموضوع بامر من بطلب من قاده عسكريين
وامني وكذلك من الولايات المتحده وهذا
محور احد قضايا الخلاف الشديده داخل دائره
صنع القرار لا سما في مجلس الحرب الذي شهد
خلال الايام الماضيه اخرها امس الاول
مشادات احداها اضطرت وزير الدفاع الى
الانسحاب بعد من الجلسه بعد ان كان
نتنياهو قد منع احد مستشاريه ومساعديه وهو
مدير مكتبه كوزير للدفاع من حضور الجلسه
وكان قبل ذلك الطاقم الوزاري الامني
المصغر قد شهد هو الاخر احتدام الخلاف
وتوترات بين وزراء مقربين من نتنياهو
ووزراء اليمين المتطرف العنصري سوتش وبن
كفير من جهه وبين الوزير جلنت وكذلك
وزير وزير مجلس الحرب بني جانس وقبل هذا
كله التهجم الذي كان على رئيس هيئه
الاركان هيرتس هليفي هذا الوضع المتفاقم
داخل دائره صنع القرار في اسرائيل بات
يعمق من ازمه الثقه القائمه بين الشارع
الاسرائيلي ايضا وقيادته السياسيه على وجه
الخصوص خاصه وان ايه ذوي الاسرائيليين
الاسرى باتوا يتوجسون خيفه من ان هذه
الحكومه لم تعد تهتم و ولا تضع في راس
اولوياتها اعاده الاسرائيليين الاسرى
المحتجزين في قطاع غزه وانها تريد مواصله
هذا الحرب حتى لو كان ثمن القضاء عليهم
وان كان الناطق باسم الجيش الاسرائيلي
بالامس حاول تبديد بعض مخاوفهم بالقول
انهم يواصلون هذه الحرب و قال بان ما
تعلنه حماس هو ياتي في اطار الحرب النفسيه
بعد الشريط الذي
عرض اسرى اسرائيليين هناك وكذلك مساله ما
اعلنه جلنت من انهم سيوا بدون ضغط عسكري
لن تتم استعادتهم حسب تعبيره وليد العمري
مدير مكتب الجزيره كنت معنا من رام الله
شكرا جزيلا